[موسيقى]
خمسه وعشرون حرفيا وحرفيه يسترجعون
التاريخ الاحساء ومروثها القديمه هنا في
عين نجمنا مهرجان واحد الاحساء في مجالات
النحت والخصيات وحياكه والنحاسيات كذلك
صناعه السجاد والفخار والسد وغيرها من
الحرف اليدويه انا لي تقريبا 20 سنه في
مجال النحت على الاخشاب
همم
استخدم اللي هو جذوع الشجر واستلهم
الافكار من جذوع الشجر وتفرعات الشجر
واعرف من ردت فعل الجمهور اعرف ان همم
المجسمات همم شيء عجيب عندهم وعليه جدا
ممتاز يعني بشكل ما يتصور
والزوار اقبال عليه يعني بشكل كثير
وعلينا احنا الحرفيين التراثيين اكثر
[موسيقى]
فعاليه متنوعه تجذب مختلفه الفئات العمريه
من زوار الاحساء وتستهدف استقطاب السياحي
من مختلف الجنسيات تتضمن عروضا للخيل
وفعاليه فنيه وثقافيه مصاحبه القديمه
والجميله جدا
يعني يسوي لك شيء شيء مباشر تقول همم نحث
فعاليات صراحه همم بين الفن وبين العراق
وبين همم الفن اليدوي الاحصاء
وابراز الهويه صراحه الوطنيه للمملكه بشكل
خاص يعني
[موسيقى]
مهرجان واحه الاحساء الذي تجري فعالياته
في سته مواقع تاريخيه استقطبت اكثر من
147,000 زائر من مختلف الجنسيات بمشاركه
نحو الستينا حرفيا وخمسين متطوع من
الجنسين كما سهم المهرجان بتوظيف مئه
وسبعه واربعين شابا وشابه في وظائف مؤقته
من الاحساء عن اللقبي العربيه
[موسيقى]